Speaker 1: All right.
I meant to get this earlier in the week.
Didn't have time, but it is very interesting.
Over the weekend, Donald Trump spoke to a
sycophant crowd in Fort Myers, Florida.
This was the Lee County Republican Party event
and it was completely bonkers.
Now, maybe the one moment where we questioned
whether the crowd was as sycophantic as we
believe them to be was when Trump insulted,
I guess we would say, or went after Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis.
There was muted applause at this moment, but
Trump pulling out the standard grievances
about DeSantis during this event.
And again, it's a Florida Republican crowd
friendlier to DeSantis, and there was only
a smattering of applause.
Speaker 3: I got 1.2 million more votes than
your successful governors campaign.
You know that.
We got 1.2 million.
Sure.
I'd love to have your support, sir.
I'd love to have you support.
I'm down at about three.
I'd love to have your support, sir.
Let's think about it.
And it was like a rocket ship after I gave
it.
Otherwise, right now, you'd have a lawyer
someplace looking for business, if that.
Speaker 1: There you go.
Now, of course, it's not really the truth,
as you might suspect.
We've looked at the polling track record for
Desantis's election.
And in fact, it was months after Trump's endorsement
that DeSantis started gaining in the polls.
So it wasn't exactly the explosive rocket
ship that Trump wants you to believe it to
be.
Extraordinarily disturbingly, Donald Trump
said that he would appoint if he became president
and had the opportunity, he would appoint
more Supreme Court justices like Clarence
Thomas.
He says Clarence Thomas is under siege for
for no good reason.
Of course, it's very scary to think that you
look at the Supreme Court and you say, oh,
we need more people like Clarence Thomas.
Thank you.
Speaker 3: I will appoint rock solid constitutional
conservative judges in the mold of Justice
Antonin Scalia and the great Justice Clarence
Thomas, who is under siege right now.
Right.
He's under siege right now for doing nothing.
He is really they're going after him right
now.
Speaker 1: He's right about Thomas is doing
nothing.
He hasn't spoken on the court for how long?
Speaker 3: Everybody else talk about appointing
conservatives to court.
I am the only one who actually did it.
I appointed almost 300 federal judges.
All told, it was pretty substantially more
than that, a record and three great Supreme
Court justices.
So that was a big that was a big thing.
Speaker 1: That was big.
So, of course, horrifying to hear as we learned
that Clarence Thomas is likely the most corrupt
and unethical Supreme Court justice in 100
years, that Trump says we need more people
like Clarence Thomas.
And this is, of course, the weaponized contrarianism.
Treachery and ism for the sake of contrarianism
that has become a hallmark of the modern MAGA
movement.
Donald Trump also doing this routine where
he says he will try to get DA's and attorneys
general fired based on essentially their political
orientation.
Speaker 3: To stop the local Marxist prosecutors
who release rapists and murderers while persecuting
conservatives.
On day one of my new administration, I will
direct the DOJ to investigate every radical
D.A. and Attorney general in America for their.
Speaker 1: Radical according to whom?
Speaker 3: Illegal, racist and reverse enforcement.
Speaker 1: Of the law, a genuinely deranged
and dangerous idea.
And understand that Trump wants.
If Trump had his way, he would get rid of
any federal government employee that simply
didn't vote for him, even if they are nonpolitical.
TRUMP That this is one of Trump's big, big
crusades.
Want to be able to fire everyone and replace
them with loyalists, even in bureaucratic
positions where politics really shouldn't
make a difference.
And he wants to do the same thing with DA's
and attorneys general.
Not going to happen, by the way.
Just completely absurd.
But it's not going to happen.
Trump also going after his own former attorney
general William Barr, criticizing him.
And if Bill.
Speaker 3: Barr had any courage instead of
worrying about being impeached by the Democrats.
These people would have all been taken care
of.
But we have to do it a different way.
If he had courage, we need people with courage.
He had no courage.
He didn't want to be impeached.
Sure to want to be impeached.
I said, what's wrong with being impeached?
I got impeached twice in my numbers went up.
He wasn't.
Speaker 1: He wasn't a brave person.
Unidentified: It wasn't a drag race.
Speaker 3: And now he sits back and pontificates.
And so Trump to show Trump that the man didn't
have courage.
He didn't have courage to go out and do what
you had to do with respect to the election.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And of course, who hired him?
It was Trump.
Trump ran on I will hire the best people and
he ended up hiring some of the worst people,
even by his own admission.
Trump's delusions of grandeur certainly didn't
slow down at all, claiming that when he won
in 2016, not only did he save the country,
he says he also saved the Republican Party.
Speaker 3: Good point.
To put it simply, on Election Day 2016, we
didn't just save America.
We saved the Republican Party.
We did.
Speaker 1: Uh huh.
Hard to believe, really, given the shambles
that the Republican Party finds itself in
today.
Trump continuing the delusions by saying he's
probably the most honest person who has ever
been president.
Even more honest than honest, Abe.
Speaker 3: There's no crime.
I got indicted for no crimes.
They're all saying even the Democrats.
Well, we don't see this as a crime if there
is no crime.
You know, a friend of mine said you're probably
the most honest person to ever be president.
Speaker 1: And then capping off a completely
insane evening.
Donald Trump then stopping at a pizza place
and taking a bite out of a slice and asking
whether anyone wants the slice that Trump
took a bite out of.
On way.
And of course, they cheer.
It is indeed a cult.
Many of them wanting a slice that Donald Trump
took a bite out of.
So this is going to be the next year.
I hate to inform people that that this is
what American politics will be like.
Meanwhile, hopefully, President Joe Biden
will keep accomplishing things.
And I think for that, we should really encourage
that.
Donald Trump speaking this afternoon in New
Hampshire at what I'm certain will be a very
unhinged campaign event.
We will cover it live on YouTube, Twitter
and Facebook.
But do not be confused.
This is indeed a cult